Homeland Security Secretary Christian
Nielsen testifies on Capitol Hill this
morning about a new DHS study it shows
that at least 549 people were convicted
in u.s. federal courts on international
terrorism related charges between
September 11th 2001 in the end of 2016
73 percent of them were foreign-born 148
of those convicted had become
naturalized US citizens another 147 were
born US citizens secretary Nielsen spoke
to us about the lesson from that study
secretary Nielsen you have a new report
that has been created by Department of
Homeland Security and the Department of
Justice what is the report say well I'll
just start by telling you it's very
concerning I think what it underlines is
that we need to be very clear who's
coming into our country make sure
they're not a terrorist the most
important figure I think from the report
is that 73 percent of all those
convicted of international related
offense of international terrorism
related offenses over the last 15 years
were foreign-born so that's quite a
substantial percentage so if you're
concerned is this a clear and present
danger of course absolutely I think the
president's been very clear I think this
underscores the need to not only
implement the executive orders that he's
issued over the past year but I feel
very strongly about going to Congress
today during my hearing and work with
them to close the loopholes that prevent
us from removing
known suspected terrorists and other
criminals in the United States so what
policy rises up out of these numbers we
take directly away from the report is we
need to continue to enhance our
screening and vetting but it also tells
us we need to continually vet those who
are here we have examples unfortunately
over the last decade of terrorist
attacks from legal permanent residents
and others who were naturalized so we
need to be able to continue up and to
the point they become a US citizen to
continue to vet them to ensure they
haven't become radicalized what does
that mean to continue to vet them how
frequent what do they have to do to
prove that they're not up to no good
well it's constantly checking against
intelligence that we gather so should
these people assume that they're under
permanent Savannah surveillance I
wouldn't say surveillance it's just it
would be a it's a very natural part of
becoming a citizen up into the point
that you're a citizen we want to
continue to make sure we understand who
you are and why you're here
but say of foreign nationals who are
responsible for murders during the time
period you've looked at here how many
foreign-born nationals are responsible
for terrorism deaths in America
tourism deaths I would have to get back
to you I think the number that we're
looking at what we've used is a number
that's related to international
terrorism related charges so that could
be a death abroad that could be a death
here that could be an attack on a u.s.
interest abroad or here but they're all
prosecuted in federal courts so that's
that seventy three percent number that's
four important in the history of America
in this period what's caused more may
have more deaths people who are US
citizens who've been radicalized or
foreign-born and who've been rounded I
don't believe I can give you that at a
none class level but I would say we're
worried about both but it isn't it isn't
it wildly the case that that's more who
are US citizens when you think of the
pulse a nightclub shooting in San
Bernardino and some of these other these
are us then were naturalized yes some of
them are legal permanent residents some
were born in America and some were born
in her so in in in those cases when
you're born in America that's the those
are the people killing just more
Americans than foreign-born I'm not I'm
not ready to commit to that again
because we have a lot of ongoing
investigations and a lot
plots that means disrupted but your
point is right we need to do more to
prevent radicalization the inspiration
of terrorism in this country the
secretary Nielsen didn't answer whether
American born or foreign-born terrorists
have caused more deaths a report from
the Cato Institute looks at the period
between the 9/11 attacks and the end of
2015 it estimates that more than three
times as many people were killed in
terrorist attacks by native-born
Americans than foreign-born individuals
yeah that's a very interesting point to
make you say that the study has some
limitations what are they and what are
the implications do you think well the
what they what the secretary is doing is
going to Congress and saying we need
more to do what we're doing and the
pushback will be well your report shows
all the people that are being arrested
and that the focus in the time of
limited attention and limited resources
should be on the people who are causing
the most mayhem and that's these
radicalized Americans and so that's
where the real focus should be so it'll
be a debate over priorities that Cato
Institute a study we looked at said over
a 41 year purity the chance of an
American being killed by a foreign
national is one in 3.6 million per year
so that's the kind of numbers that the
study will have to combat as people are
saying how much money and time and
attention should we pay to various parts
of the homeland security threat John
thank you